[Music]
hey i want to address an email i get
this email a lot and
um let's just jump right into it this
one's from gordon says i'm asking your
thoughts on opposite sex friends
and what are good boundaries in marriage
um man this is such a great question i
get this all the time and
it it doesn't have to be it can be
anybody you're attracted to anybody that
um otherwise would be weird because
you're married you've got somebody um
who you pledged your allegiance to for
the rest of your life and it may be that
your
partner at work your co-worker is
someone of the opposite gender someone
who's attracted to you somebody who is
cool to hang out with and you end up
spending eight hours a day with them you
actually spend more time with that
person at work than you do with your own
spouse happens a lot
um it may be like hey we are in the
middle of a project let's go grab lunch
real quick let's just run um hey i gotta
get to work early tomorrow you grab
coffee and let's whatever
hey did you hear that new band they are
awesome check this out
hey we had to have this really hard hr
conversation we got to go through this
and that
workplace
solving problems together
accomplishing projects together
um
it can slowly it can be an intimate
interaction right you're talking about
things that drive you crazy that are
hard you shed tears together you cheer
together you you hit your goals together
you fail together things you just get
messy
so for me here's the the two or three
driving things
number one
in my past i've known who i'm getting on
dangerous ground
when i keep secrets
when i think
i need to delete that
not that somebody no one's you know i'm
not sexting or anything like that i'm
saying
when i've got private jokes
that i don't try to fill my wife in on
um
i have a few friends in my life who are
very close to me that i've had friends
for years and they are wives of my
buddies
my wife is friends with that intimate
group of people i mean we have been ride
or die for years and years and years
um
i trust them with my children i trust
them with my life
they are free to
communicate with my wife that's just
there's a an intimacy there
um
uh kelly and i exchanged messages
regularly hey this call is coming in
make sure you check i just sent the call
sheet make sure that hey tomorrow's show
is going to be this time so that's just
part of being in the business world
together and working on a project
together
it's when that phone dings and i see it
and i delete it really fast or i think
it's a little bit too far
or
man i really hope so and so text today
oh i sent a meme that i think is
hilarious and i can't wait can't wait
can't wait can't wait till see if they
get the joke or if they respond
it's when suddenly i realize oh man i
think i'm investing more in that
friendship
than my marriage
that's when we
things start getting messy
um
when in this in the last few years when
i go if i have to go grab coffee with
somebody if i have lunch with somebody i
actually text my wife now hey i'm going
to grab some lunch with so and so i'm
going to run grab coffee with so-and-so
in fact i don't even do that anymore um
i take a group of people um it just
keeps everything clean i don't know
what's going on in other people's lives
i don't know what's going on in their
hearts and in their minds and in their
marriages and in their friendships and
in their dating relationships i don't
know
and i don't want to get into all that
mess
i am responsible for taking care of my
home and my marriage and so i'm going to
keep stuff as above board as possible
here's what i want to call out though
that can be
how good old boy networks get
perpetuated
one of my favorite stories ever i won't
use her name she's so awesome she's one
of my favorite
leaders ever
she was um a leader at a university and
she was always the only woman at the
table
she was a riot one of the funniest
funniest people i've ever met much less
people that i worked for much less
um
uh
senior executive who's a woman
but she tells this hilarious story about
how they were around a board room and
they were going at it it was a a heavy
meeting there was a lot of hard opinions
people were frustrated and they were
loud and they were getting back on each
other and
they took a break hey we gotta let's
just take a break let's go get coffee
and let's go to the bathroom
so she says all these men get up and
pile in and go into the bathroom
i'm stuck getting coffee by myself
and before before i get coffee i go run
to the ladies room
i go in the bathroom
and i hear them
through the wall they're still having
the meeting
they're still talking about what
so-and-so said and what about this and
we can't afford that and we're gonna
have to cut our budgets by this percent
she said i got done go in the bathroom
and i just walked right around and i
kicked that door open
and said if y'all are still having this
if we're still having this meeting i'm
coming in
and to which all the men were like oh
sorry sorry we'll be out quickly and she
laughed and they laughed
and then they all came out and they sat
down back down at the table and
continued the meeting
why is that important
it can be a way to perpetuate the good
old boys club oh i don't i don't go to
lunches i don't do these things um
this is just i i don't go to lunches
with anybody other than my husband and i
think that's wise i think that's so wise
and it's a way to perpetuate the gap in
the workplace so here's here's my
solution to that
number one don't have meetings over
lunch give yourself a break during the
day if you're working that much for an
extended period of time i get their
seasons but if you were working like
that man you're on a pace for burnout
just decide
i i take private lunches man i don't
work through lunch
number two take groups with you go on
groups man keep everything above board
laugh together as a group
share and exchange things as a group
like be open and vulnerable with each
other as a group
it's just wise
there is no he said she said i felt
uncomfortable
he asked this question or she made this
comment and now we're in a mess
everybody keeps their hands above board
this isn't me being prude this isn't me
being old school this is me trying to be
wise
and
to keep equality in mind
now
could i go grab lunch with my friend
melissa
my oldest buddies todd's wife yeah
i
could would todd grab lunch with my wife
absolutely i wouldn't think twice about
it in fact i would love that he's
a lot more level-headed and wise than i
am i think they're probably good for my
wife's soul
my friend john taking my yes all that
yes yes yes
i'm talking about workplace stuff i'm
talking about secrets i'm talking about
sneaking around i'm talking about that
moment when you realize
i hope
my workplace friend texts me more than i
hope my wife does
that's when you're in dangerous ground
so whatever rules you put in place for
your workplace whatever rules you put in
place with your spouse it goes back to
intentionality have the conversation
with your spouse you may have been going
to coffee with your work mate for years
and you didn't even know your wife has
no idea your husband has no idea and you
tell me like no don't do that it makes
me feel comfortable i feel weird now you
gotta have a conversation and it's not
about oh you don't trust me it's not
about that it's about playing with fire
it's about being safe it's about being
wise
it's about you're going to put yourself
in a position that you've got no cover
that somebody can say anything about you
and it's just he said she said or he
said he said or she said she
she shed she shed that's
she shed she shed
i don't know i feel like we just we just
dumped into a home depot commercial real
real quick it got weird you all know
what i'm saying be wise don't keep
secrets be intentional go in groups
there you go